tal y amanece con incertidumbre y lo
hace también después de que el
presidente edu que haya estado unas
horas en la ciudad en un consejo de
seguridad con él con el ministro
interior el ministro de defensa la
alcalde y la gobernadora en el que
habido un consejo de seguridad para
tratar de levantar los bloqueos que hay
en la ciudad
duke ha ordenado el mayor despliegue
posible de fuerza pública y también ha
querido mandar un mensaje a los jóvenes
a través del alcalde asegurando que son
conscientes de que hay un problema con
la juventud en colombia esto sucede
después de que el domingo se viviese
gran tensión después de que la minga
indígena que tiene cinco mil miembros
aquí en la ciudad de cali regresa sea la
universidad del valle donde están
alojando se temporalmente se encontraron
con una manifestación en dos puntos
acomodados de la ciudad en la que los
manifestantes les impidieron pasar y
finalmente recibieron disparos y viendo
a varios miembros de la minga indígena
para destacar que las naciones unidas
han criticado esta situación violenta
recibida ayer por parte de la minga por
último hay que destacar que la minga
llegó a la ciudad de cali para
los diferentes bloqueos que rigen en la
ciudad desde el 28 de abril y han estado
también haciendo los labores de control
tratando de que civiles armados que han
aparecido en camionetas blindadas no
atacasen contra los manifestantes